seven-year-old isabella bohannon was hit
by a jet ski last weekend
while she was spending time with family
on the colorado river
she's now in a medically induced coma at
sunrise hospital
tonight family and friends gathered
outside her room to pray for her
recovery
madison kimbrough was there she joins us
live near desert and maryland parkway
tonight
with a story you'll only see here on 8
news now madison
yes isabella's families described her as
a warm and an amazing person they were
all out here earlier today honoring her
life
and hoping for a speedy recovery
she's formed a bond with every single
person she comes across whether she's
known you for five years or five seconds
she's she connects with everybody on
such amazing
levels life changed abruptly for
seven-year-old isabella bohannon
just last weekend she was enjoying the
sun with her family near bullhead city
arizona and in just a blink of an eye
tragedy struck
while isabella was looking for seashells
and playing in the water
a jet ski ran directly into her leaving
her seriously hurt
she is currently in a coma and fighting
for her life at sunrise children's
hospital
she's still fighting as hard as she can
as fast as she can
she's trying to come back for her
recovery
on sunday family and friends came out to
honor the seven-year-old's life
we're praying that god would do a
miraculous thing in isabella's life
from holding hands in a circle in prayer
to writing special notes and bringing
balloons and gifts
today we're gathered here for prayer to
help send the love and the energies
up to isabella's room we're out here
every day people just come out
say hi to the family send your love your
vibes your positive vibes your energy is
up to the room she needs everybody's
prayers everybody's love right now
the family also created hashtag izzy's
dream to bring awareness of
accidents like this
and bullhead city police say the mother
and sister were also hit by the jet ski
but they are healing
as far as the driver of the jet ski that
person stayed on scene and
is cooperating the family came up with a
gofundme page to pay
for the medical bill so if you would
like to help we have a link up on our
website
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now